we're back with another exciting episode
of Kos
king of the statues today I told you
will be some epic I am proud to bring
you part of my childhood but that's
right after this banging intro I'm proud
to bring you a snippet of some of the
stuff that I grew up loving I mean I
grew up you know reading comic books and
loving all the Marvel stuff all the DC
stuff all my mal donation Universe stuff
remember when they'd mixed up Marvel and
a mix of DC that was great I had a great
time with that also when they had what
was that Image Comics was spawn and
everybody but I'm was a big cartoon dude
like GI Joe Thundercats
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
hanna-barbera on Saturdays but there's
one cartoon that stuck with me it uh it
emphasize teamwork you know overcoming
obstacles sometimes they were at a human
deficit but nothing stopped the gold
chain
I can still hear that music just
thinking back so today I give you a
piece of my childhood this statue is
like no other this gigantic probably
wanted to tell the statues I got and
since its y4o
that's crazy
one of the most detailed statue sideshow
has ever put out it is a part of my
collection I believe at some point in
time it will become that Holy Grail if
you're a real Voltron fairy and you
don't have this you're not a real boy
something it feels like the statue is
made out of pure metal it's insane
the base is heavy it's like he's
standing on the moon and on the base
it's very intricate it has each number
for every lion the way they appear on
the Lions the feet each piece of the
statue like each statue park was named
specifically alone so you get the legs
separate then you get the torso separate
you get the arms separate and you get
the head severed like this like when it
was forming a remember sting back to it
it's phowa you understand how many times
I'm rushed home from school just to make
sure that he got that robeast a hundred
percent fact shout out to women who
think about you saying effect all day
but I'm telling you that show was one of
the best and I was so happy when I found
out that Netflix had reimagined it and
brought it back out for you for today I
watched that one two that series is
really good but I love the old classic
so this statue is reimagined where some
of the old and some of the new nice
little slim fit it's like very solid
like more like Tony Stark
built this one nice also it has a
light-up feature with the eyes so the
eyes light up the sword is insane I must
say sideshow out did they self with this
one and this one is a must have in every
collector of Voltron tune in next week
where if you thought this was crazy I
got something that's gonna knock your
socks off
thank you for tuning in like following
subscribe to iron Lords podcast and go
to Lords of game in.net
where you can see the new up-and-coming
kyo at Kos and also combat talk with the
King and of course that iron Lords
podcast love ya and flashpoints
with lower Cognito and lordy pontus
we're doing it out here for how join us
also stick around the other video the
unboxing is gonna beat it so you can
listen to a beat this guy won't be
talking you can enjoy yourself and watch
the visuals high quality pitches for you
guys until next week Kos king of the
statues
[Music]